[Musique]
b
bon
on salue avec une vidéo il arrive qu'on
voit pas trop où je veux en venir avant
la fin et je crains que ce soit
particulièrement le cas cette fois
aujourd'hui je vous propose une
promenade autour de l'idée de
responsabilité histoire d'éclairer la
question massive que j'ai mise en titre
de quoi sommes nous responsables
je voudrais commencer par une petite
mise en garde la question de la
responsabilité est vertigineuse
idéalement il aurait fallu aborder
l'histoire de la représentation morales
que l'on se fait de l'individu il aurait
fallu traiter l'évolution de l'idée de
la responsabilité individuelle le rôle
que la religion a joué comme celui de la
confiance on a raison celui du
libéralisme mais cela aurait fait idiot
de trois heures
idéalement j'aurais fait donc une série
de vidéos sur le sujet j'aurais pris le
temps de faire tout un tas de recherche
j'aurais tenté de couvrir le maximum de
dimension du problème il y allemand cas
malheureusement ma vie professionnelle
ne me le permet pas j'ai fait de mon
mieux malgré tout mais comme je le
disais ce n'est qu'une promesse on va
donc pas faire le tour de la question je
ne peux que proposer quelques éclairages
incomplet
d'abord une petite précision sur le
terme lui-même être responsable c'est
littéralement pouvoir répondre de
quelque chose trop souvent on confond
responsabilités et cause un bon exemple
pour y voir clair c'est la situation de
l'instituteur ou de l'institutrice
instituteur n'est pas la cause des
enfants n'est pas leur père à tous mais
il en est responsable
l'institutrice n'est pas la cause de ce
que font les enfants dans la classe mais
elle en est responsable
ici je voudrais éviter les
circonvolutions sémantique et parler de
responsabilité morale en un sens très
simple et intuitif à savoir que dans le
cas d'un acte moralement répréhensible
ont déclaré une personne comme
moralement responsable si on a tendance
à l'avoir comme fautive si on a envie de
dire que c'est de sa faute et donc si on
n'a pas envie de lui pardonner on
considère une personne comme n'étant pas
moralement responsable dans le cas
contraire où on a envie de lui pardonner
et l'écart et que ce n'est pas de sa
faute avec sa rente est j'ai eu envie de
poser une question super naïve à quoi
ressemblerait le citoyen idéal bien sûr
avec une question pareille je fais de la
provoc il n'est évidemment pas question
de réduire l'engagement politique à
l'échelle individuelle ça m'a surtout
permis de faire une miniature clip
haters il s'agit en fait interroger le
rôle que joue dans l'engagement
politique ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
regard individualiste j'appelle regard
individualiste cette tendance spontanée
à voir autrui comme une personne comme
une entité indépendante avec une
identité qui lui appartient et qu'on est
en droit de juger et donc c'est ce
réflexe de penser qu'un individu peut
être une bonne personne ou une mauvaise
personne si ce regard existe et je crois
qu'il existe alors il vous semble
pertinent d'interroger la fonction qui
joue au sein d'une pensée politique au
sein de notre manière de regarder la
société
on pourrait commencer à entrer dans le
sujet en mentionnant et les scooters
c'est un basketteur turc qui joue en nba
et qui a essayé d'attirer l'attention
sur les conditions de travail dans les
usines naquit en chine il a parlé d'
esclavage moderne je ne crois pas que la
technologie soit exagérée moi je vois ça
et mon premier réflexe c'est de penser
que c'est cool que ce serait chouette
que ça incite les gens à arrêter
d'acheter tel aviv
immédiatement j'ai une petite voix dans
ma tête qui me dit que l'achat
responsable c'est un peu la plage du
bobo et effectivement on voit bien la
caricature du bobo qui achètent bio
local qui troque son scoot pour un vélo
etc on se moque gentiment parce qu'on
voit dans cette attitude une
responsabilisation naïve de l'individu
on a d'un côté un gouvernement qui ne
prend aucune mesure écologique et de
l'autre un discours du genre penser à
trier vos déchets fait du vélo
regardez d'où viennent vos légumes bon
c'est un peu absurde c'est la logique du
colibri on célèbre le petit effort
individuel plutôt que de responsabiliser
les pyromanes
le gros souci de ce truc là c'est que ça
détourne du vrai problème de la lutte à
mener à savoir la transformation du
système qui a causé une société
dysfonctionnelle comme la nôtre j'aurais
tendance à penser que si on fait
attention à ces achats pour se donner
bonne conscience effectivement on prend
le risque de tomber dans ce travers
hyper individualisant si on pense qu'en
achetant un produit responsable on a
fait sa part alors on est carrément
tombé dedans donc a priori je suis pas
trop pour la responsabilisation
individuelle
mais est ce que ça veut dire pour autant
que mon regard politique et entièrement
libérées de la perspective
individualiste ma manière spontanée de
regarder le monde d' évaluer
l'organisation sociale de juger ce qui
est juste ou injuste d'attribuer les
responsabilités est ce que tout ça se
fait sans intervention du regard
individualiste j'en doute un peu
comme on l'avait évoqué ici il faut
distinguer croyances de surface et
croyances profond je peux penser
consciemment que l'individu n'est pas le
problème que c'est contre le système
qu'il faut lutter tout en entretenant un
ensemble d'affect une disposition
d'esprit qui inconsciemment nourrit un
regard individualisant du coup il y a
une chance comment un comportement
perpétue cet individualisme je vais être
franc avec vous si on imagine monsieur x
est malade y qui touche le même salaire
ayant les mêmes frais incompressibles
monsieur x comme madame y travaillent en
plus comme bénévole dans une association
ils ont tous les deux conscience que la
priorité est la lutte systémique l'hiver
approche et le froid impose l'achat
d'une veste monsieur x ne se résignent
pas trop et achète une marque dont les
usines profit des esclaves ouïghours
madame y fait un petit travail
d'investigation et trouve une marque
fairtrade
madame y ne considère pas que c'est à
charles à des douanes d'aucune façon
elle considère simplement que c'est le
strict minimum bon ben j'ai beau ne pas
être trop pour la responsabilisation
individuelle je trouve quand même qu'il
vaut mieux faire comme madame y pourquoi
est ce une histoire utilitariste c'est à
dire est ce parce que je considère que
la morale se résume aux conséquences de
nos actes je ne sais pas oui bien sûr
l'impact de l'achat de manuels y est
toutes choses égales par ailleurs moins
mauvais que celui de monsieur x mais je
sais aussi que ça reste un impact minime
et je veux pas validé l'idée que c'est
le consommateur qui doit transformer la
société
c'est peut-être aussi une histoire du
anthologique genre une affaire de
principe de cohérence si tu es contre l'
esclavage tu dois essayer d'éviter de
cautionner des industries esclavagiste
il faut immédiatement précisé que c'est
pas toujours facile certains efforts
coûte davantage que d'autres par exemple
tout le monde n'a pas les moyens
d'acheter un phare phone bah on va pas
dire aux gens qui ne peuvent pas se
l'acheter de ne pas acheter des
smartphones tout court et de se couper
de leurs amis simplement parce que
l'achat d'un smartphone classique n'est
pas responsable il est logique de
prendre en compte la pénibilité du
sacrifice quand même moi quand je
débranche ma freebox parce que je pars
deux jours de chez moi je ne le fais pas
parce que je veux faire ma part je ne le
fais pas parce que je crois aux effets
d'une action je le fais parce que je ne
vois pas pourquoi je ne le ferai pas
c'est pas exactement pareil ça ne nous
coûte rien bref il faut distinguer deux
problèmes bien différent d'un côté on
peut vouloir responsabiliser l'individu
vis-à-vis d'un problème disons locales
peuvent par exemple faire de la peine à
un ami par maladresse c'est une
situation qu'on peut cadrer
de l'autre côté on peut vouloir
responsabiliser l'individu vis-à-vis
d'un problème d'ordre systémique comme
par exemple l'écologie ou le sexisme
ordinaire ce qui peut conduire à dire
que chacun doit faire sa part dans ce
cas il faut reconnaître immédiatement la
question de la position de l'individu à
l'intérieur du problème systémique notre
responsabilité le rôle qu'on joue dans
une situation morale ou politique dépend
étroitement
position de pouvoir pour l'écologie vous
savez ce que j'en pense le réchauffement
climatique est d'abord la responsabilité
des gouvernements et des industriels je
ne vois pas pourquoi ce serait à
monsieur x dont la vie est déjà bien
fatigante de devoir ajouter des
contraintes supplémentaires
en prenant en compte la totalité des
facteurs à savoir la culpabilité des
dirigeants et les difficultés de la vie
de monsieur x on a envie d'excusés le
fait qu'ils oublient de faire le tri
sélectif
pour le sexisme ça pourrait être quoi
faire sa part et bien par exemple quand
on est un garçon reprendre un pote qui a
un comportement déplacé vis-à-vis d'une
fille on pourrait avoir envie de
rétorquer que ça pourrait aussi être aux
autres filles présentes de le reprendre
mais c'est une lecture de la situation
qui ne prend pas en compte les rapports
de force en jeu c'est ignorer que si
c'est une fille qui fait une remarque il
ya des chances que le garçon balayent
ces remarques d'un revers de main en
laissant entendre qu'elle n'a pas
d'humour ou qu'elle est coincée or si
c'est un garçon qu'il dit le sens de sa
remarque paraîtra très différent et
beaucoup plus difficile à ignorer c'est
parce qu'un homme ne subit pas de
discrimination sexiste qu'on est en
droit d'attendre de lui qu'il
intervienne et intervenir c'est ici une
façon d'en assumer la responsabilité
qu'en est-il des situations qui ne sont
pas explicitement lié à un problème
systémique par exemple un adulte qui
tape un enfant ça semble assez simple on
n'a pas spontanément envie de replacer
l'action dans un ensemble plus vaste qui
nous conduirait à excuser son geste mais
on peut garder à l'esprit que cet
ensemble existe probablement un adulte
qui bat un enfant est peut-être un
adulte qui a lui-même subi les sévices
dans son enfance et que la société n'a
pas su protéger
c'est peut-être aussi une personne qui
subit tout un tas d'injonction viriliste
qui le détermine à considérer la
violence comme l'expression naturelle on
peut imaginer plein de choses qui
conduirait à penser que cet acte
horrible et bien l'effet d'un système
c'était en partie le propos du joker de
todd phillips
si la société ne se préoccupe pas des
individus fragiles des situations
dramatiques risque de survenir
c'est pas facile de percevoir ce qui
relève du système ou de l'individu comme
manger de la viande bien sûr que la
culture dans laquelle nous sommes nés et
culture carnivore qui a largement
déterminer nos habitudes alimentaires
mais en même temps aujourd'hui les
informations sont disponibles et acheter
de la viande s'est donné son
consentement à une industrie responsable
une quantité vertigineuse de souffrance
et puis en même temps il faut garder à
l'esprit que certaines personnes qui
vivent dans la précarité subissent de
telles contraintes de temps de gestion
budgétaire de conservation des aliments
qu on leur pardonnera la consommation de
viande
un truc qu'il faut interroger c'est
cette tendance à croire que la
responsabilité individuelle à la
responsabilité collective s'excluent
mutuellement au fond il paraît tout à
fait possible de tenir l'individu et la
société pour responsables en même temps
par exemple dans le cas d'un père qui
bat son enfant il n'y a rien à cohérent
ou de contradictoire à vouloir tenir
l'individu pour responsable de son
action et à vouloir rappeler le rôle que
joue la société dans cette action c'est
pas tout l'un ou tout l'autre c'est pas
soit c'est entièrement de la faute du
père soit c'est pas du tout sa faute
c'est entièrement la responsabilité de
la société
et c'est précisément notre défi est
notre difficulté que de tenir ensemble
les deux angles de lecture
comprendre la responsabilisation de
l'individu est un problème quand elles
masquent la responsabilité collective
quand elle fait oublier la
responsabilité de la société est l'
inverse
faut-il aussi dire que la
responsabilisation du collectif et un
problème quand elles masquent la
responsabilité individuelle
et bien c'est un peu moins clair à mes
yeux
peut-être parce qu'on a tendance à
surestimer la capacité des individus à
contrôler leur décision je ne veux pas
rentrer à nouveau dans la discussion sur
le libre arbitre comme je lé déjà fait
là je ne cherche pas à relancer le débat
avec les compatibilités ici je dirais
que peu importe comme on appelle ça il
ne veut pas sous-estimer l'influencent
de l'environnement sur les replantations
intellectuelle et morale que produit
l'individu sur les émotions qu'il
ressent sur les valeurs auxquelles ils
adhèrent
cette année hassan biker instruments
américain très connu à acheter une
maison à 2,7 millions à los angeles
parker se déclarent de gauche
précisément socialistes citant marx
régulièrement ça a suscité quelques
remous disons et c'est donc une
situation intéressante pour nous à deux
niveaux au moins d'abord oublions le cas
spécifique de bikers et imaginons
simplement un youtuber ou un streamer
qui fait ses vidéos tout seul et gagne
soudain beaucoup beaucoup d'argent en un
certain sens on pourrait dire qu'il n'a
exploité personnes pour devenir riche
pour autant on ne sait bien plus le
pouvoir augmente plus la responsabilité
augmente
entre volé une pomme pour manger parce
qu'on n'a pas un euro en poche et volé
une pomme simplement parce qu'on n'a pas
envie de le payer alors qu'on est plein
aux as ce n'est pas la même
responsabilité morale dans un cage peut
acheter la pomme dans l'autre je ne peux
pas et ça change tout un premier truc à
dire c'est que le succès ça donne du
pouvoir et donc ça implique une plus
grande responsabilité
ensuite qu'est ce que ça change si notre
youtuber se déclarent de gauche d'abord
peut-être que ça implique qu'il
reconnaisse que son succès en un certain
sens ne lui appartient pas parce que son
succès est rendue possible par une
structure un système une économie donc
par d'autres gens qui travaillent mais
aussi parce que ses idées son discours
sa rhétorique sont nés de la rencontre
de tout un tas d'influencés diverses
pour le diabète mans il n'aurait jamais
eu un tel succès sur une île déserte
c'est parce que la société a rendu
disponibles certaines ressources qu'il a
pu avoir un tel succès comme dit michael
chandelle quand bien même on concédera
l'idée que les individus sont
responsables de leur talent au sens de
cause comme si notre youtuber imaginaire
ne devait qu'à lui-même d'être devenu
bon quand bien même on considérait une
idée aussi naïve on rappellera
immédiatement que l'individu n'est pas
responsable de la valeur que la société
attribue à ses talents
j'y peux rien si être bon au tir à l'arc
ça n'offre pas les mêmes possibilités de
succès qu être bon au foot
pour le dire autrement on doit toujours
notre pouvoir donc notre puissance
d'influencé aux autres au collectif au
social c'est l'organisation de la
société qui nous confère un pouvoir et
c'est donc normal de considérer qu'il en
découle une responsabilité alors
quelle est cette responsabilité qui est
on en droit d'attendre de notre youtuber
chaque relation implique une multitude
de contrats plus ou moins tacite si un
ami me demande je peux te confier un
secret et que je réponds oui un contrat
tacite est signé et on considérera que
mon ami est dans son bon droit s'il se
plaint que j'ai répété son secret à
plein de gens
c'est vrai de manière encore plus
implicite si je vais voir un film qui se
présente comme inspirée d'une histoire
vraie tout de suite on peut dire qu'un
contrat est établi je ne dois pas
m'attendre parce que ce soit hyper
précis et fidèle à la réalité mais en
même temps ça ne peut pas non plus être
complètement n'importe quoi du genre
dans la réalité c'est un suicide et dans
le film c'est un meurtre bon bah de ce
point de vue il n'est pas fou d'imaginer
qu'un youtuber aussi parce tacitement un
contrat avec son public
quelqu'un qui présente ses vidéos comme
de la vulgarisation par exemple s'engage
à un minimum de rigueur de l'été
intellectuelle et d'humilité épistémique
le fait que notre youtuber se présente
comme étant de gauche change forcément
la nature du contrat
youtuber qui nous informe d'emblée que
l'objectif de ces vidéos et
l'enrichissement personnel passe avec
son audience un contrat différent du
youtuber qui promeut des idéaux de
gauche
implicitement même si ce dernier ne
devient pas patrons d'entreprises qui
exploite ses employés on peut avoir
envie de se demander si cet
enrichissement trahi le contrat tacite
passé avec celles et ceux qui en
regardant massivement ces vidéos ont
effectivement permis ce succès
à mes yeux il ya deux choses à révéler
ici
d'abord j'ai demandé qu étant en droit
d'attendre de lui et je crois qu'il faut
s'arrêter dans cette question une
seconde elle est très différente de la
question que suis-je en droit d'attendre
de lui en fait je voudrais attirer votre
attention une seconde là dessus même si
ça nous semble tout à fait normal quand
on responsabilise un individu cela ne
suppose pas qu'il soit tout à fait
normal pour moi de responsabiliser tel
individu
si je dis on doit tenir x pour
responsable de ce n'est pas la même
chose que je dois tenir x pour
responsable d'eux donc je me demande ce
qui me confère à moi le droit de
responsabiliser tel individu qu'est ce
qui légitime que tel individu
responsabilise telle autre et notamment
en fonction des rapports de force en jeu
il ya un sacré violences illégitimes
quentin privilégier un dominant
responsabilise des individus précaire au
2me personne qui a de quoi s'acheter à
manger ne peut pas juger responsabiliser
et condamner moralement une personne qui
vole une pomme pour survivre
cet exemple est facile mais je vous
laisse le dupliquer
dès qu'on a du pouvoir qu'ils soient
économiques sociales culturelles
on ne peut pas responsabilisés un
individu moins puissants sans produire
une grande violence il faut avoir
conscience de cette violence se demander
si la situation justifie qu on la
provoque
donc je crois plus généralement il faut
se demander dans chaque situation ce qui
nous confère le droit d'obtenir xpo
responsable de son comportement
ensuite la deuxième chose à noter c'est
donc la question de la cohérence 6e et
youtube heures fait des vidéos se
déclarant de gauche on est en droit de
s'attendre dans le cas d'un succès à ce
qu'il ne concentre pas les pouvoirs on
pourrait imaginer avec tout cet argent
qu'ils embauchent des partenaires qui
toucherait le même salaire que lui et
qui jouirait de la même autorité
vis-à-vis des décisions à prendre
c'est pas une proposition radicale pour
revenir un autre exemple précédent si tu
dis que tu es contre les oppressions les
injustices tués contre l' esclavage
située contre l' esclavage des passants
c'est cautionner une entreprise comme
naquit surtout si tu a effectivement le
capital économique et culturelle pour
choisir une autre marque
mais dire un truc pareil est-ce que ça
retombe pas dans la caricature du type 1
tu critique la société et pourtant tu
participes à la société
mais en même temps il ya bien les
situations où la contradiction est
effectivement problématique non j'ai un
pote il est prof est alors qu'ils
discutaient avec une inconnue dans un
café il a dit quelque chose comme je
suis prof j'aime mon taf je suis en
guerre contre mon institution la dame
lui a répondu alors il faut démissionner
sinon vous n'êtes pas cohérent
la réponse de mon pote était un peu
abstraite mais je trouvais séduisante il
disait quelque chose comme ça au fond il
faut distinguer deux temporalités il y à
la temporalité institutionnels
gouvernementale les ministres passent
les réformes avec et puis il ya la
temporalité de l'enseignement des idées
qui elle beaucoup plus longue en gros il
rappelle en un sens il ne travaille pas
pour le ministre comme si finalement
l'enseignant répondait à une autre
autorité supérieure à celle du ministère
à savoir des principes éducatifs qui
encadrent avant tout sa relation élèves
et aux contenus qui leur transmet dans
l'éducation justement on peut vivre des
principes et en même temps être tentés
de faire du cas par cas or le cas par
cas c'est pas toujours très équitable
dois-je donner de mon temps à l'élève
qui vient me demander de l'aide oui at
on envie de répondre immédiatement mais
est-ce si simple si on se souvient que
c'est un temps et d'énergie que je ne
consacre pas à l'élève qui n'a pas eu le
courage de venir me demander du soutien
cette question se dit plus de
constamment à qui ou à quoi dois-je
quelque chose un principe ou un calcul
conséquentialiste peut-il prendre le pas
sur l'interaction réel avec un être
humain
puis j'ai décidé que telle personne ne
mérite de mourir non bien sûr mais plus
décidé qu'elle mérite d'être insulté
c'est moins évident je sais qu'il n'ya
pas de réponse définitive à ces
questions mais pour autant j'ai quand
même envie de les poser
la difficulté c'est aussi de placer le
curseur si j'ai un pote qui fait une
blague sexiste je pense que c'est mon
devoir de le reprendre quitte à lui
faire de la peine à la fois pour qu'il
ne recommence plus et par souci de
cohérence avec mes idéaux si j'ai un
pote qui veut acheter une veste d'une
marque dont les usines profitent des
esclaves ouïghours je pense que j'ai le
droit de le signaler que c'est pas
terrible comme décision mais je m'arrête
où on aime bien faire la distinction
entre action obligatoire réaction
surérogatoires l'action surérogatoires
c'est celle qui va au-delà de ce qu'on
est censé faire si je vois un enfant qui
se noie et que je n'ai qu'à tendre la
main pour le sauver c'est une action
obligatoire si je ne le fais pas tout le
monde pourra que j'ai fait une faute
morale grave
si pour le sauver je suis obligé de me
sacrifier et de mourir et que je décide
donc de ne pas le faire on sera plus
indulgent avec moi on considère que se
sacrifier une action héroïque et qu'il
est logique de ne pas attendre ça de
tout le monde mais cette distinction ne
me satisfait pas pour une raison dont on
peut distinguer trois dimensions 1 ça
encourage l'opposition entre les l'âge
d'un côté et les héros de l'autre ceux
qui tout de même un peu simpliste
s'attend à réduire des individus à une
action comme s'il suffisait à définir la
valeur morale de l'individu si
l'individualisme est une sorte de
réductionnisme en ceci que sa coupe
l'individu tout qui permet son émergence
ici c'est la même chose l'individu moral
est réduit à ses décisions
2 dans le même ordre d'idée cela va dans
le sens d'un réductionnisme morale comme
si une action morale pouvait être
évaluée à l'intérieur du contexte ultra
limitée de son occurrence comme si elle
n'était pas liée à un vaste ensemble
d'influencés diverses
3 cela enferme la compréhension morale
dans le schéma binaire coupable
innocents qui est un avatar de
l'opposition bien mal et ce mode de
pensée et moralement stérile plutôt que
de se demander quel comportement en
voudrait que la société encourage et
comment y parvenir plutôt que se dire
qu'il faut inventer de nouvelles valeurs
de nouvelles manières de vivre ensemble
on se borne à reconnaître ce que la
société dans laquelle on vit indique
comme étant autorisés c'est à dire moral
est interdit donc immoral
cela encourage une disposition d'esprit
super égoïste se demande est ce qu'on a
le droit de faire c'est en fait se
demander ce à quoi on a droit et donc
comment je vous dire de ce droit comment
en profiter c'est donc se demander dans
quelle mesure la société nous autorise à
défendre nos intérêts propres cette
logique n'habitent pas se dire voilà
société que je veux défendre je vais
donc promouvoir un certain type de
comportement mais plutôt il y a des
choses qu'on n'a pas le droit de faire
tout le reste c'est ok comme s'il
interdit nous autorisait et poussait à
jouir de ce qui est autorisé
c'est à dire comme s'il interdit nous
convainquent est plus ou moins
consciemment qu'il est naturel de se
préoccuper d'abord et avant tout de la
jouissance de nos droits
mais il ya des gens qui poussent pour
transformer l'organisation sociale les
militants or on comprend bien avec une
logique binaire comme celle ci que le
militantisme soit difficilement audible
dans une société comme la nôtre tout
simplement parce qu'il sort du cadre
autorisé interdite
ce qui pourrait ou devrait paraître
comme une chose tout à fait normal
logique légitime est perçu par tout un
pan de la population comme une forme de
radicalisme car quoi de plus normal que
de se préoccuper de l'organisation de la
société et d'avoir à coeur qu'elle soit
la plus juste possible
donc forcément si monsieur x est
persuadé qu'il est tout à fait légitime
de lettres préoccuper que de son propre
bonheur quand madame y essaie d'attirer
son attention sur un dysfonctionnement
social et en appelle à sa solidarité
donc un certain sens de la
responsabilité collective le hic ce sens
tout agressé et encore plus quand le
dysfonctionnement en question est une
source de plaisir pour monsieur x là je
peux vous dire que c'est très difficile
dès qu'on touche à un truc que les gens
aiment faire ça se braque
moi par exemple j'essaie de faire
comprendre aux gens autour de moi que
l'exploitation des animaux est une chose
très grave j'essaie de leur faire
abandonner la viande mais soyons honnête
je n'y arrive pas je ne sais pas comment
la faire comprendre
pourtant mon entourage n'est pas
complètement dépolitisé si je gagner
plein d'argent et que je frauder le fisc
mes amis ma famille me ferai des
remarques constamment si j'étais fan de
ces mots ou plus simplement de macron
mon entourage livrer des énormes crime à
chaque fois qu'on parlerait politique
pourtant ils ne se rendent pas compte
que ça me fait sa puissance 10 chaque
fois que je vais moins manger des
animaux je les ai orientés vers des
livres
j'ai fait des démonstrations super
réglementée rien n'y fait et ce n'est
même pas comme si on veut opposer des
arguments intelligent et construit alors
quoi je suis témoin d'un comportement
dans tout indique qu'il est moralement
et politiquement super répréhensible la
manière douce ne fonctionne visiblement
pas que reste-t-il l'insultent la
culpabilisation les coûts et comment
évaluer ses modes d'action on pourrait
se demander ce qui sera le plus efficace
mais aussi comment ça va m'affecter - je
risque de perdre des amis si je leur
parle violemment à chaque fois
est-ce que je vais devoir moral m'impose
de sacrifier ma vie sociale pourquoi
devrais-je autant me responsabiliser
je comprends bien la pertinence qu'il y
à a pointé du doigt le comportement des
autres mais je garde à l'esprit que
l'autre est le produit d'un système d'un
déterminisme dans l'environnement
culturel et idéologique autrui à ses
angles morts ses limites et d'ailleurs
moi aussi je ne suis pas parfait non
plus je ne peux pas oublier que
certaines choses m'échappent et donc par
extension que je ne sais même pas ce qui
m'échappe
comment puis-je être sûr de la manière
avec laquelle je responsabilise autrui
alors faut-il se détourner de la cnps
individuel considérant que chaque action
est d'abord et avant tout le produit du
système on se serait de se préoccuper du
cas par cas et on s'occuperait au
contraire des grandes structures qui le
rendent possible par exemple je cesse de
me préoccuper de ce que mange mon
entourage et toute l'énergie dépensée à
essayer de les convaincre je la déplace
dans un engagement associatif pour les
droits des animaux
mais en même temps cette logique a ses
limites si je vois un individu sur le
point de [ __ ] le feu à un chat pour le
plaisir il serait bien normal que
j'intervienne pour l'en empêcher je ne
vais pas penser aux cet individu est le
produit d'un système qui biaise notre
conception de l'animal non humains il
n'est pas responsable de son acte je ne
vais pas perdre mon temps ici je me
demande si on touche pas ici à une forme
d'impasse d'abris en gros on sait que la
structure procès de l'individu
ce qui implique que l'individu est le
produit de son environnement est en ce
sens que toute action est toujours prise
dans un rapport collectif on n'agit pas
seul on agit en réaction à d'autres
actions mais dans le même temps on
n'arrive pas pour autant à sortir
complètement de l'échelle individuelle
quand j'agis je n'éprouve pas
spontanément le collectif qui est tissée
dans mon action mon action me semble
cadrer par une expérience locale limité
j'ai l'impression de l'apercevoir dans
sa totalité je me sens être la cause de
l'action et c'est pour ça que je me
tient pour responsables de mon
comportement
zemmour est comme tout le monde le
produit est donc la marionnette d'un
ensemble de causes qui le dépasse son
comportement est le résultat d'une
certaine configuration invectives un
ensemble de désir et d'émotions diverses
qui ont été causés par diverses
influences il ya de la peur de
l'angoissé de la haine de la colère un
besoin de dominer etc etc après tout
tout le monde vit des émotions
semblables mais ce mélange spécifique
d'affect qui caractérise et meaux a la
particularité de produire un
comportement fasciste
malheureusement il y en a plein d'autres
des fascistes
zemmour lui pose spécialement problème
car il est en position de puissance en
quelque sorte il est le porte voix de
cette configuration affective et celle
ci est dangereuse car fasciste il faut
donc combattre zemmour en tant qu il le
corps individuel qui incarne un danger
social
ici c'est pas très difficile cela paraît
évident qu'il faut responsabiliser moore
pour le danger qu'il représente au
niveau collectif certains peuvent
déclarer nous souffrons de la puissance
d' influence de zemmour cela suffit à
justifier qu'on ne responsabilise et
qu'on veuille le combattre au niveau
individuel c'est pas tellement plus
compliqué je peux trouver injuste que
l'individu zemmour a plus d'influencé
sur moi et moment que j'en ai sur lui
son monde il y à une asymétrie qui
justifie aisément l'opposition vivement
n'a été élu par personne donc au nom de
quoi at il autant de pouvoirs sur ma vie
au nom de quoi peut-il imposer ses
opinions dans le monde dans lequel je
vis ce n'est pas le libre marché des
idées un c'est que la société donne plus
de pouvoir à certains individus plutôt
qu'à d'autres pour des raisons
totalement arbitraire et sans aucune
justification morale et politique et
puis nous subissons ces rapports de
force dissymétrique
là je crois que la responsabilisation
individuelle a du sens parce que c'est
une manière de pointer du doigt le
dysfonctionnement du système
mais c'est plus compliqué quand le
rapport de forces est égal si je
rencontre un fan de zemmour suis censé
me comporter avec lui de la même manière
que si je rencontrais est mort lui-même
a priori pas trop les deux sont des
pantins en proie des influences diverses
mais il y en a un qui représente un plus
grand danger d'un point de vue
utilitariste j'aurai un meilleur impact
sur la société si j'arrive à contrer et
moi en lui-même mais du point de vue
déontologique
indépendamment des répercussions de
leurs actes les deux représentent le
même ils incarnent les mêmes idées à
combattre c'est un peu comme les comptes
twitter on ne les considère pas de la
même manière selon qu'ils ont dix
abonnés ou 50 milles mais ça c'est la
considération consciente qu'on a de leur
impact sur le monde c'est de la
stratégie militante sait prendre en
compte la force d' influence
qu'en est il de la manière dont on se
représente l'individu derrière le compte
twitter la représentation que l'on se
fait de la personne qui écrit les tweets
se construit en grande partie
inconsciemment dans tel ou tel cas cette
augmentation va générer en nous des
sentiments plaisant de la sympathie
parce qu'on se retrouve dans certaines
valeurs parce qu'on se dit même que on
pourrait peut-être être potes dans
d'autres cas la représentation que l'on
se fait du tweetos se nourrit des
tensions plus ou moins consciente qui
créent de l'animosité et cette animosité
et très clairement tournée vers la
personne je veux dire tout bêtement
qu'il me semble très difficile voire
impossible de ne pas associer un
comportement à une personne et qu'il est
donc très difficile de ne pas juger les
personnes ça me fait penser à cette idée
est de signer l'offre de 6 noeuds il
faudrait détester le péché par le
pêcheur ce qui est problématique parce
qu'on ne peut pas vraiment distingué
l'individu de son comportement
il ya une version laïque dans le reste
de rigueur et de game c'est la faute du
jeu et non des joueurs sauf qu'en effet
on peut se dire que si les joueurs
arrêter de jouer au jeu celui-ci
disparaîtrait tout seul mais en même
temps les joueurs sont conditionnés à
jouer ils ne peuvent rien faire d'autre
depuis qu'ils sont nés on les encourage
à jouer
alors voilà je suis un peu perdue je
peut pas à la fois penser que les
individus sont des sommes de
comportement déterminé par un
environnement et considérer qu'il faut
les blâmer pour leur décision de l'autre
côté je ne peux pas observé des
comportements dangereux ou immoraux sans
rien faire ou du moins sans vouloir
intervenir pour changer quelque chose on
pourrait répondre il suffit de se
concentrer sur le militantisme
systémique c'est à dire se focaliser sur
la transformation du système avant tout
mais cette transformation se nourrit de
la responsabilisation individuelle par
exemple c'est ce qu'on a vu avec
l'affairé wayne sting c'est la
cristallisation de tout un monde
d'oppression sexistes autour de la
figure d'un individu qui en devient
symbole mettre un nom et un visage sur
un problème permet de l'identifier et
cela facilite le discours et on peut
faire le pari que la ferme aux ânes
steen a fait gagner en popularité le
mouvement tout
le principe même de ce mouvement et que
la désignation d'individus fautif permet
de révéler un dysfonctionnements
systémiques on est donc en plein dans
notre problème est ce que la sororité
aurait pu obtenir un tel coup de boost
avec une approche des individualisante
du problème ce n'est pas sûr on pourrait
défendre l'idée que ce qui justifie un
tel mode d'action militants c'est
précisément une dissymétrie dans les
rapports de pouvoir me to ne désigne pas
simplement un ensemble d'individus mais
à travers eux également des situations
sociales ou ce sont toujours les hommes
qui se trouvent en position de force en
ce sens l'individu devient le symbole
situation qui le dépasse
du point de vue métaphysique macron
n'est pas responsable de ce qu'il est à
savoir un arriviste politiques
incompétents avide de pouvoir entouré de
conseillers tout aussi incompétents et
avide de pouvoir mais du point de vue
moral et politique une fois qu'il a le
pouvoir n'avons pas d'autre choix que de
le tenir responsable pour les injustices
que son comportement et ses décisions
reconduit
mais comment ça se passe entre gens qui
n'ont pas de pouvoir ou qui ont
globalement le même pouvoir que fait
tout comment fonctionne la
responsabilisation entre nous entre amis
bon déjà on peut se demander s'il ya des
situations de parfait équilibre de force
on sait que pour un couple par exemple
déjà c'est rarement le cas est entre
amis on ne gagne pas tous le même
salaire exactement on n'a pas tous la
même quantité de temps libre pour se
renseigner sur nos choix et leurs effets
politiques on n'a pas trop eu la même
éducation non plus les mêmes affinités
pour certaines valeurs et il ya beaucoup
de violence symbolique entre amis
beaucoup de moments où l'un domine
l'autre mais également on a plus
facilement accès aux informations qui
peuvent expliquer le point de vue de nos
amis est potentiellement un angle mort
politique si mon ami et fils de boucher
ne doivent pas adaptés ou discours sur
l'exploitation animale considérant qu'un
certain nombre de ces représentations
mentales risque de faire sérieusement
obstacle
est ce seulement une histoire de forme
s'est il simplement de dire attention ce
que tu fais est grave avec un ton doux
et sincère bienveillance
j'ai déjà essayé ça ne marche pas des
masses
alors commencer tant qu'on a le droit de
reprendre quelqu'un de le corriger de le
culpabiliser
ou est-ce qu'on arrête la responsabilité
individuelle je veux dire précisément
dans notre manière de nous comporter
avec autrui parce que si on ne
responsabilise pas les individus
vis-à-vis de leur impact sur le reste de
la société on va dans le sens d'une
société libérale où seul importe la
possibilité pour chacun de poursuivre
son intérêt propre et on voit ce que ça
donne et en même temps on ne peut pas
tomber dans la glorification de
l'individu exemplaires on ne va pas
validé une société qui distribue des
bons points à des héros et qui blâme des
loosers c'est pas possible certains
espèrent peut-être se cacher derrière
une position ultra simpliste du genre je
ne suis responsable que de mes actes
mais c'est absurde si je passe devant un
enfant qui se noie et que je continue
mon chemin c'est cela mon acte c'est de
continuer mon chemin plutôt que de le
sauver et c'est pareil si je vois une
personne en agressé une autre dans la
rue et c'est la même chose quand je vois
des gens participer à une industrie qui
fait souffrir et eu des milliards
d'êtres sensibles ne pas me préoccuper
des injustices sociales c'est un acte il
ne suffit pas d'être activement impliqué
dans une action injuste pour être
responsable une injustice il suffit par
exemple de laisser faire c'est ce que ne
comprennent pas les privilégiés ils
disent j'ai réussi ma vie honnêtement je
ne fais de mal à personne je ne vois pas
pourquoi je devrais me préoccuper de
ceux qui souffrent mais en fait c'est
pas la question le problème est là des
gens souffrent à cause d'une
organisation sociale dysfonctionnelle on
peut se persuader que le système
fonctionne bien pour se rassurer et se
déculpabiliser mais si on regarde un peu
honnêtement le truc on voit que les
écarts de richesse on veut plus en plus
grands du coup ne pas se préoccuper de
ce dysfonctionnement c'est comme passer
devant l'enfant qui ce droit sans rien
faire
on entend parfois dire pour aider les
autres il faut d'abord s'aider soi-même
bon il ya plusieurs manières d'entendre
cette idée j'en ai déjà parlé mais ça
vaut le coup d'en remettre une couche en
un certain sens cette phrase est tout à
fait juste situé dépressive si tu vis
une crise si tu souffres n'est pas en
situation d'aider les autres la douleur
te fais tourner vers toi même c'est bien
normal
il y a un sens où cette phrase est
complètement ridicule si tu va plutôt
bien cherché à être encore plus heureux
ça va probablement avoir avant tout un
impact sur ta vie et pas tellement sur
celle des autres
mais il ya aussi un problème intéressant
soulevées par cette phrase si on la rend
formule ainsi pour aider les autres il
faut connaître les autres et pour
connaître les autres il faut d'abord
comprendre le rapport qu'on a aux autres
notre manière de nous représenter autrui
il faut se connaître soi même c'est à
dire qu'il ya quelque chose qui me
semble assez pertinent dans le fait
d'affirmer qu'il est très difficile
d'être une aide pour autrui si on est
aveugle aux raisons plus ou moins
consciente qui nous font agir si on n'a
pas perçu un peu clairement la forme de
nos désirs de nos craintes de nos
angoisses si on ne voit pas clair le
système de valeurs auxquelles on adhère
dans quelle mesure mon altruisme et
parasité par mon égoïsme
est-ce que je peux vraiment prétendre
m'engager pour les autres si je ne
comprends rien mes propres motivations
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit une
question à traiter à la légère mais bien
sûr elle fait un peu peur cette question
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'elle ouvre
la porte à un manque de développement
personnel on dit aux gens occupez vous
de vous d'abord alors qu'en fait on
reste plutôt d'un monde d'entre elles
mais sur quoi va se fonder cette entrée
sur quelle conception de l'individu sur
quelle image du monde on est tous prêts
à s'accorder sur le fait qu'il faut un
minimum de culture politique économique
et sociale pour avoir un regard
pertinent sur le monde environnant il
faut aussi développer une attitude un
minimum critique vis-à-vis des idées et
des valeurs qui circulent et à certains
égards tout cela relève du développement
personnel
j'ai tendance à faire le pari que si
longtemps rigoureusement de s'observer
soi-même sans chercher à être re +0 1 je
parle strictement d'observation et de
compréhension eh bien on développe son
empathie et donc un plus grand sens du
collectif on devient meilleur coéquipier
ou une meilleur coéquipier
mais c'est mon pari et je ne suis sûr de
rien
et je reconnais que tout ça ressemble à
une impasse une contradiction est résolu
individus et collectifs
ça fait penser un jour je participe et
un live qui concrètement mois et est
arrivé sur la table la question c'est
quoi être de gauche c'est une question
qui me fascine et j'ai déjà essayé
d'écrire un script de vidéos là dessus
sans succès pour l'instant
sur le moment j'avais esquissé un début
d potez c'est franchement pas solides à
l'heure c'est à prendre avec des
pincettes
en fait je pensais à deleuze et guattari
et alors qu'on fait de devenir lier
cette opposition majeure et mineure
pour aller vite le majeur c'est le
dominant tandis que le mineur c'est ce
qu'ils trouvent un moyen d'échapper aux
forces dominantes c'est comme une forme
d'émancipation vis-à-vis d'un statu quo
dominant ainsi kafka par exemple parce
qu'il subit dans son pays la langue
allemande décide précisément d'écrire en
allemand pour tracer des lignes de fuite
comme ils disent pour se libérer de
l'emprise de l'allemand en inventant une
langue dans la langue en réinventant la
demande s'il avait été écrit en tchèque
il aurait été dans l' esquive quelque
part ils n'auraient pas travailler la
matière même de la légation la chose qui
s'est imposé à lui la langue allemande 2
et guattari disent donc que le devenir
et forcément associé à du mineur on ne
devient pas du majeur le majeur c'est ce
qu'on est par défaut à cause de
l'idéologie dominante dans mille
plateaux ils disent par exemple qu'on
peut avoir un devenir féminin mais pas
de devenir masculin parce que le modèle
masculin et le modèle dominant il n'y a
pas de devenir de cet ordre bah voila
vous voyez peut-être venir je me demande
si on peut être de gauche peut-être
qu'on ne peut que devenir de gauche
peut-être faut-il constamment travaillé
pour échapper à des représentations
mentales qui se construisent
inconsciemment qui vous domine et qui
sont spontanément de droite au sens où
elles ont tendance à responsabiliser
l'individu pour ses succès ses échecs au
sens où elle invite à juger les
personnes par défaut à cause de
l'environnement culturel et idéologique
dans laquelle nous sommes nés nous
voyons autrui comme une personne
autonome et nous le jugeons ainsi et
peut-être faut-il constamment faire un
travail de déconstruction ses réflexes
pour arrêter de voir spontanément les
individus comme des points isolés et
autonome afin de réussir à les voir
davantage comme des lignes dans un
système
en ce sens on dira qu'on peut pas être
de gauche genre une fois pour toutes
comme si on était complètement
déconstruit mais on peut avoir des
comportements de gauche qui sont autant
de manière d'échapper à ses réflexes de
droite qui conduisent par exemple juger
les individus mais honnêtement je ne
suis pas très sûr de mon hypothèse dans
l'abécédaire de l'os propose une
conception de l'opposition de droite
gauche sur lui être de droite c'est
comme la manière dont on écrit une
adresse postale d'abord soir ensuite ma
rue ensuite ma ville ensuite mon pays et
peut-être ensuite le monde
je pense d'abord à ce qui est proche de
moi par exemple pas ma famille est
ensuite à skier plus éloignés et être de
gauche ce serait la dynamique inverse ce
serait savoir que les problèmes du tiers
vannes sont plus proches de nous que des
problèmes de notre quartier
bon évidemment qu'on pense d'abord à soi
et à ses proches quand ont est précaire
quand on galère pour vous faire à la fin
du mois ça ne fait pas de nous quelqu'un
de droite mais quand on est privilégié
si avec nos proches on n'est pas
précaire
la question devient est ce qu'on
considère que c'est bon on n'a pas à se
préoccuper des inconnus qui souffrent ou
au contraire est-ce qu'on vous dit que
la gravité de l'injustice ne dépend pas
de la distance ou de la proximité
toute personne qui se pense de gauche et
qui se reconnaît comme privilégiés comme
n'étant pas précaire devrait se poser
cette question quand est-ce que je me
préoccupe de ce que je ne connais pas et
qui souffre quand est-ce que je m'en
préoccupe ça veut dire quand est ce que
j'y pense mais pas seulement ça veut
dire aussi quand est ce que je fais
quelque chose pour eux et peut-être plus
précisément quand est-ce que je sacrifie
quelque chose de mon confort personnel
parce que je me préoccupe de cette
souffrance étrangères
quand est ce que la considération de
cette souffrance étrangères veut conduit
à agir indépendamment voir contre mes
intérêts personnels si la réponse est
jamais je crois que vous connaissez le
problème et c'est donc une affaire de
cohérence encore de déontologie alors
pour en revenir à la question de la
responsabilisation en gardant à l'esprit
ce problème de cohérence interne on
pourrait au moins proposer cette réponse
aussi incomplète et insatisfaisante soit
l on peut responsabiliser les individus
en fonction de leurs propres exigences
c'est un élargissement de la règle d'or
ne pas faire aux autres ce qu'on
voudrait pas qu'on nous fasse en ne pas
laisser faire aux autres ce qu'on
voudrait pas qu'on nous fasse
autrement dit ne pourrait se
désintéresser légitimement d'une
injustice que celui ou celle qu'ils ne
percevraient pas la situation comme
injuste si il ou elle en était victime
en gros pour savoir si on peut
légitimement se détourner d'une
injustice il faut essayer sérieusement
de se mettre à la place de ceux qui la
subissent
alors pour essayer de répondre aux
problèmes de la responsabilisation
individuelle je propose un système
variable
je ne responsabilise pas autrui pour ce
qu'il ressent et donc pour ce que ses
affects le conduisent à penser à croire
ou même à faire mais je le
responsabilise vis-à-vis de ses actions
1 du point de vue de leurs effets sur le
monde et deux vis-à-vis des principes
déontologiques qui justifie à ses yeux
ces actions ainsi on laissait d'invités
autrui à se comporter selon des
principes auxquels lui-même adhère je
n'ai pas à me poser la question de la
légitimité à responsabiliser autrui en
quelque sorte je joue le rôle de miroir
je ne fais que le renvoyer à ses propres
exigences morales quant à ma propre
responsabilité individuelle je ne me
responsabilise pas moi-même pour ce que
je ressens je garde à l'esprit que
l'image que j'ai de moi même comme
personne et très certainement illusoire
mais je responsabilise celui qui en moi
est capable d'observer ses sentiments
croyances actions afin d'éprouver une
forme de puissance qui m'aident à
adapter le meilleur comportement
possible sans souffrir de frustration ou
de culpabilité quand je n'y arrive pas
et peu importe que cette impression de
puissance soit illusoire ou non
c'est comme pour le pari de pascal le
fait de jouer le jeu de cette puissance
a des effets bénéfiques
elle me donne l'énergie nécessaire pour
remplir les exigences morales par
exemple c'est ce qui le rend assez fort
pour ne pas me déresponsabiliser quand
la société aurait bien besoin que je me
responsabilise justement du genre j'y
peux rien c'est ce que la société a fait
de moi ce genre d'attitude n'aide
personne
pour terminer je leur ai posé deux
questions est ce qu'une personne qui
aurait complètement intégré l'idée d'un
déterminisme total d'un univers
entièrement mécaniste où chaque décision
est situé dans une chaîne un fini de
poser des faits et qui aurait donc
complètement abandonné toute forme de
responsabilité individuelle est ce
qu'une telle personne aurait à votre
sens tendance à adopter un comportement
plutôt égoïste et toxique
l'abandon total de la responsabilité
individuelle
aurait-il nécessairement pour
conséquence le développement d'une
attitude moralement répréhensible du
type du coup je ne pense qu'à ma gueule
rien à [ __ ] des autres j'ai envie de
faire le pari que non j'ai envie de
croire que si on la boit même
entièrement et radicalement toute idée
de responsabilités individuelles ont
fait certes disparaître la possibilité
du blâme mais aussi celle des louanges
et je pense que sans possibilité de
louanges donc de fierté de mérite c'est
l'idée même de succès ou de réussite qui
s'effondre aussi et je crois que si cela
disparaît la très large majorité des
désirs égoïstes disparaissent comme on
dit ici on ne vit pas dans une société
matérialiste
on vit dans une société symbolique où
tout est affaire de céline et dont deux
statues la société de consommation est
une société de compétition mais si on
est libéré de l'illusion selon laquelle
notre réussite réflètera quoi que ce
soit de notre valeur personnelle sans
cette addiction au feedback narcissique
qui fait qu'on s'y croient qu'on peut se
prendre au sérieux peut-être bien qu'on
laisserait mourir le désir de succès le
désir d'avoir du pouvoir et c'est le
danger bien sûr c'est d'avoir
suffisamment intégrée de déterminisme
pour se dédouaner de toute
responsabilité individuelle sans avoir
été suffisamment loin dans la prise de
conscience pour pouvoir effectivement
abandonné la fonction symbolique du
désir de succès et le besoin de réussite
personnelle et du coup on se laisse
aller soi même tout en continuant à
entretenir le désir égoïste donc il
n'est pas sûr qu'il faille encourager la
prise de conscience de la responsabilité
individuelle parce qu'il est sans doute
très difficile d'atteindre le point où
cela coïncide avec un comportement
réellement néo gaulliste
la seconde question mélange ensemble les
perspectives utilitariste et
conséquentialiste je voudrais qu'on
imagine deux individus
x11 grand force de sa responsabilité
individuelle il sait que ses actions ont
des conséquences pour autrui il est donc
très préoccupé par la recherche de
principes moraux et politiques en
lesquels placer sa coque il se met une
énorme pression sur les épaules pour
agir correctement et par conséquent il
met la même pression sur les autres dont
ils scrutent chaque action aussi ses
choix et ses actes ont in fine et plus
d'effet néfaste que bénéfique pour faire
simple disons que même s'il est bien
intentionnés il fout la merde malgré lui
il s'embrouille avec des caméras
militants il génère de la tension dans
les associations où ils s'engagent ils
parasitent la lutte de ses alliés et
c'est bon on peut lui reprocher plein de
choses mais pas sa sincérité son
dévouement et son engagement
de l'autre côté y a complètement
abandonné l'idée de responsabilité
individuelle pour lui le monde n'existe
pas c'est une vaste illusion entièrement
produite par sa conscience même la
souffrance est illusoire en ce sens ils
considèrent ne rien devoir à personne
mais jamais rien dans son comportement
n'est toxique sa seule présence apaise
les tensions et génère de la cohésion
quand les minorités opprimées lui parle
elle de se rendre comprise est
véritablement écouter pour le dire
autrement y n'impose aucun rapport de
force
son comportement au quotidien je veux
dire ses actions ses interactions les
individus dans la vie de tous les jours
sont celles d'un allié de tous les
dominer on peut lui reconnaître tout ça
en même temps y ne se bouge pas trop le
cul pour changer le monde alors avec
quel individu êtes vous le plus à l'aise
avec qui vous voulez vous menez votre
combat politique qui est votre citoyens
idéal aller voilà c'est tout pour cette
fois c'était déjà bien long j'espère que
ça vous a plu si vous voulez soutenir la
chaîne vous savez quoi faire à bientôt